las fuerzas ucranianas anunciaron haber
logrado liberar un pueblo tomado por
Rusia se trata del pueblo de macarril
situado en un enclave estratégico pues
está en la retaguardia de la batalla que
se está librando en quiebre de hecho que
Moscú logre ocupar toda esta zona que se
encuentra a poca distancia de kiev
significaría permitirle justamente un
avance también por vía terrestre y
precisamente en esta ciudad sigue en
estos momentos en vigor un toque de
queda que impide que la población la
pueda salir a la calle salvo en el caso
tenga que dirigirse a los refugios
antiaéreos en Mario por la castigada
ciudad del Sur ucraniano en cambio se ha
anunciado la abertura de nuevos
corredores humanitarios que en las
próximas dos horas deberían permitir la
evacuaciones de centenares de personas
que buscan un refugio en otras zonas del
país y mientras el presidente ucraniano
brother miceleski ha vuelto a hablar de
la posibilidad de un encuentro con el
presidente ruso Vladimir Putin algo que
sin embargo difícilmente ocurrirá a la
brevedad puesto que Moscú no ha dado
ninguna señal de tener la intención de
aceptar este ofrecimiento de las
autoridades ucranianas